I know you said earlier you don't think
the Jews are the chosen people per se
anymore no they're of of of God yeah but
uh are they are they in the sense like
Michael Brown says because God preserves
them yeah makes them in a sense chosen
no no no God preserves them because he
will not completely cut them off the
problem with Michael Brown and I love
the brother because he's a Jew sometimes
he
overemphasizes the jewishness or the
focus on Jew because he's a Jew I I
expect that so he's imbalance if I'm
going to be honest he's imbalan it's not
to attack him he's a great man of God
but he's imbalance in many ways he's
imbalance in that area he's imbalance
with his trying to explain or defend the
nonsense among the charismatics so he's
imbalance there as well so he has
imbalances like we all do okay I'm
imbalance you're imbalance right he's
imbalance none of us have perfect
theology but as far as scripture is
concerned the Jews as the chosen people
ended with their rejection of Jesus
destruction of the temple and Jerusalem
that doesn't mean God will wipe out the
Jews and has nothing to do with the Jews
God will still bring in Jews and save
them and engraft them into the church
the true chosen people of God can I
prove that to you yeah go ahead yeah
okay let me show you Jesus Jesus saying
that because the Jews rejected him God
will now cut him off and take away the
Kingdom from them go to Matthew 21 now
for the rest of you writing write down
because he's gonna read all of it
Matthew 21 33- 44 Matthew 21 33- 44 but
we're not going to read all of that
you're going to read from 37 to
44 last of all sent his son to to them
saying they will respect my son but when
the vine dressers saw the son they said
to themselves is this the heir come let
us kill him and seize his inheritance so
they caught him threw him in the
vineyard and killed them therefore when
the owner of the vineyard came what will
he do to those wine dressers 41 they
said he will severely destroy those
wicked men and rent his vineard to those
Vine dressers who will give him the
fruits of their Seasons Jesus said to
them okay now hold on what did they say
the owner will do after they kill his
son his
beloved he will severely destroy those
wicked men okay he's going to destroy
the wicked men because they killed his
son right yeah okay now keep
reading uh from 42 okay Jesus said to
them have you never read in the
scriptures the stone which the builders
rejected has become the Cornerstone this
is the Lord's doing and it is marvelous
in our eyes therefore I tell you the
kingdom of God will be taken from you
and given to a nation bearing its fruits
okays on this you caught it sorry you
see what 43
said read 43 again to a nation bearing
its fruits right okay what did Jesus say
to the Jews read the 43 so it can sink
in read 43 again what did he say to the
Jews therefore I tell you the kingdom of
God will be taken from you and given to
a nation bearing its fruits what more do
you want when Jesus says I'm your last
chance but now you're going to reject me
and kill me and the kingdom will be
taken away from you and given to another
nation that will bear its
fruits right so are the Israelites God's
kingdom
people no unless they accept the Messiah
right there right right he said it not
me Jesus said it kingdom is taken away
it's going to be given to another now
let me show you some more connections go
to Exodus 19
5-6 Exodus 19
5-6 pay attention guys I'm giving you
meat here it's not it's not a popular
teaching but it's a Biblical one so be
honest to scripture even though
Evangelical churches May condemn you and
never invite you to their Church who
cares now therefore if you if you will
Faithfully obey my voice and keep my
commandment then you shall be my special
possession out of all the nations now
notice the language God says to Israel
you'll be my special what possession and
then read what else he's going to do
with them for all the Earth is mine and
you will you will be to me a kingdom of
priests and a holy nation these are the
words which you shall speak to the
children of Israel now guys catch it he
said you Israel if you keep my
Commandments will be a priest and a holy
nation right a chosen people right right
okay now see what Peter does with the
promise of God Peter talking to Gentile
Christians go to 1 Peter
2:5 guys notice what God Said to Israel
you are a priest a holy nation My Chosen
possession if you do what I say notice
the language notice the language go now
to 1 Peter 2:5 what did Peter a Jew say
to the
church you also as living stones are
being built up into a spiritual house as
a holy priesthood to offer up spiritual
sacri Aces that are acceptable to God
through Christ Jesus sound familiar he
says you Christians consisting of
Gentiles as well as Jews you're a
spiritual house you're a holy priesthood
you are a holy priesthood and the house
offering sacrifices to God right right
now read 1 Peter 2 veres 9-
10 but you are a chosen race a royal
priest prood you just blew my mind
that's Exodus 19 5-6 where God says
Israel if you obey me you'll be a chosen
people a holy race but Peter took the
language and applied it to the church
read 1 Peter 29-10 again read it again
but you are a chosen race a royal
priesthood a holy nation and a people
for God's Own possession so that you may
declare the goodness of him who has
called you out of Darkness Into His
Marvelous Light in times past you you
were not a people but now you are people
of God you had not received Mercy but
now you have received Mercy dude you
just blew me away Peter took what God
Said to Israel if you obey me you'll be
my chosen people a holy nation of
priests offering my praises and
sacrifices and he took that language and
he applied it to the church Peter did
that he applied it to the
church why is Peter taking the promises
of Israel and applying it to the church
but now hold on go to Revelation 1
5-6 Revelation 1
5-6 right here you guys catching it or
no you the rest of you would you go to
sleep on me just don't sleep on me
because then I'm going to suffocate
ration 1 5-6 okay and from Jesus Christ
who is the faithful witness the
firstborn from the dead and the ruler of
the kings of the earth to him who loved
us and washed us from our sins in his
own blood and has made us Kings and
Priests to his God and his father to him
be glory and Dominion forever and ever
amen hold on Jesus made all the Gentiles
all the nations who believe in him he
made them Kings and
Priests right but isn't that what God
Said to Israel you are a kingdom of
priests a holy nation
yeah so why is the
language applied to Israel now apply to
the churches of Jesus Christ Now read
Revelation these verses show that we're
the new Israel right yes read Revelation
59-10 we're almost
done ran 5: 9 and 10
isah I saw that big huh
H Revelation 5: 9- 10 and they sang a
new song saying you are worthy to take
the scroll and to open its seals for you
are slain and have redeemed us to God by
your blood out of every tribe and and
tongue and people and nation and have
made us Kings and Priests unto our God
and we shall reign on the earth wait you
have taken men from all tribes Nations
and languages and made them a kingdom of
PRI to our God who will reign on the
Earth right so what was said about
Israel is now applied to the church All
Peoples of various languages from
various tribes who have been purchased
by the blood of Jesus he's made all of
us Jews and Gentiles the kingdom of
priests a holy nation God's possession
to Reign on
Earth yeah so it's not just Israel is it
no this answers the other question
no I didn't say Israel's completely
replaced because the Jews are also
engrafted into the spiritual body of
Christ who believe it's not Israel
that's the chosen people it's the church
that's the true Israel spiritual Israel
but that church includes ethnic Jews and
Gentiles who are made one by the blood
of
Christ
right has everyone got it now let me
give you the final one that's going to
be mind-blowing go Isaiah 60:14 what did
God say he would have the Nations do to
Israel whom they took captive what is
God going to make the Nations do before
Israel for taking Israel captive Isaiah
60:14 the sons also of those who
Afflicted you shall come bowing before
you and all those who despised you shall
bow themselves down at the souls of your
feet and they shall call you the city of
the Lord the Zion of the Holy One of
Israel okay did you guys Carolyn
everyone really pay attention because
you're going to sit in awe of what
you're about to read God said all those
Nations that took you captive I'm going
to make them bow before The Souls of
your feet acknowledging that I love you
and I love the city right right so God
is going to make the Nations do that for
the Jews in Jerusalem right right what
are the Nations going to do Bow before
The Souls of the feet of the Jews right
right you sure you guys got it everyone
got
it because now notice what our lord
Jesus does with this promise Revelation
3 read seven and 8 now get ready to be
blown away Jesus the Jew the Jewish
Messiah notice what he's going to do
with it Revelation 3:7
to8 my own opinion is that they still
have a special place in God's heart
because he can't take back his word the
Jews are still chosen of God when they
belong to Jesus and believe in Jesus
because then they'll be part of the
church and therefore still be beloved of
God who said they're completely rejected
and hated I didn't say that I said the
Jews as a race are not God's chosen
people but God loves all nations and
still loves the Jews and he loves them
for the sake of Abraham Isaac and Jacob
so that's why he will still bring Jews
and save them by bringing them to Jesus
and once they believe in Jesus they're
now the chosen race of God because
they're part of the church and the
church is the chosen race and the church
includes Jews and
Gentiles anyway coming back to the issue
do you guys remember what Isaiah 60:14
said God said to the Jews who would be
brought back into Jerusalem after their
captivity by the Nations I'm going to
bring all the nations and I want to make
them bring your sons and daughters back
to Jerusalem and then I'm going to make
them bow before The Souls of your feet
you Jews to acknowledge you're my people
and to honor Jerusalem my city right
remember that I'm going to make them bow
before The Souls of your feet okay let's
go to Revelation 37
to8 to the angel of the church in
Philadelphia right he who is Holy he who
is true he he who has the king of David
he who opens and no one shuts and shuts
and no one opens says these things I
know your Works look I have set before
you an open door and no one can shut it
for you have little strength and have
kept my word and and I and have not
denied my name okay now who's he saying
this to to the
Jews you saying it to the
church okay so what church where in
Philadelphia can you guys caught it
Jesus is not saying it to the Jews right
right Jesus is saying it to the church
in Phil Philadelphia
right everyone got it before I move on
the church in Philadelphia he's saying
it to the church
right you you got it too Roman because
he went yeah I got it y you sure okay
now read verse n notice what Jesus says
to the church the Christians at
Philadelphia everyone pay attention be
blown away Revelation
3:9 listen I will make them in synagogue
synagogue of Satan who say they are Jews
and are not but lies
listen I will make them come and worship
before your feet to know that I have
loved you that should blow you away
Jesus now reversed the blessing of
Isaiah 64 6014 flipped it on the Jews so
in Isaiah
60:14 what was the Gentiles bowing
before the feet of the Jews Jesus fli it
and now is going to make the Jews bow
before the feet of the church so that
the Jews will know I love the
church and you still want to tell me the
Jews are the chosen people
and insult Jesus Christ by saying that
what he said to the church is not true
those Jews that rejected me they're not
true Jews they're liars and their
synagogues is where Satan
dwells their synagogues are not a house
of worship God isn't worshiped there
their synagogues belong to the devil
their father that's what Jesus just
said so you're going to say anti no
you're a liar and a slanderer because I
love and worship ship Jesus as my God
and he's Jewish I worship the God man
God who became a Jew and I love his
Blessed Mother Mary as the greatest
woman that God created and she's Jewish
and I love her more than my mother and I
love his Apostles and Paul is my hero
who's Jewish so you Wicked lying
slanderer don't you dare say I'm
anti-jewish
anti-semitic okay would you catch what
Jesus said two things those who reject
me they are liars they're not real Jews
and secondly the synagogues where the
Jews worship who don't believe in Jesus
their synagogues belong to the devil God
is Not worshiped there because they
don't know God now how many of you are
going to be bold Witnesses and say Amen
all
synagogues that reject Jesus that gather
there and think they worship God but
hate Jesus reject Jesus they're not
worshiping God because God is Not there
those synagogues are controlled by the
devil their true father until they
repent and love and worship Jesus that's
what Jesus just said man I didn't say it
Jesus said
it so now what are you guys going to do
with Jesus saying that promise of Isaiah
60:14 hear me out that promise of Isaiah
6014 where the Nations will bow to the
Jews before their feet I'm going to flip
it on the Jews and I'm going to make the
Jews bow before the feet of my church so
the Jews will know I jesus the Jewish
Messiah am in love with my church and if
you reject me I reject you and you're
not my people because you got to believe
in me to be part of my church and then
you're my people that's what it says
right there I didn't write Revelation
3:9 you know Revelation 3:9 John the Jew
and Apostle filled with the Holy
Spirit they're chosen in the sense
they're the ones who built the church
anyway so yep thank you so is that clear
right all right so I hope that answered
your question